[Musique]
ils font partie de ceux qui sont à
l'origine du peuplement de notre île la
communauté chinoise immanquablement
associé à nouvelle boutique du quartier
a fêté dignement dans les jardins de la
villa du département
une nouvelle année placée sous le signe
du chien une soirée qui a débuté par les
traditionnelles danses du dragon et
d'union dans son discours de bienvenue
le président des départements série
médium a rappelé à quel point il était
important de célébrer le temps fort du
calendrier chinois dans une société
multiculturelle où le vivre ensemble et
la tolérance fait figure de modèle
si nous pouvons réussir à nous projeter
vers la chine
nous devons aussi savoir attirer et
accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions
les chinois qui souhaitent venir sur
notre île
faire vivre notre
culture diversifiée et je suis heureux
que la communauté chinoise vivant ici à
la réunion des français et bien
participé à nos côtés et je salue le
travail de mon ami andré thien ah koon
qui va oeuvrer aussi avec nous coiffés
en sorte que nos liens se rapproche
encore plus une communauté chinoise très
dynamique qui a montré à quel point elle
était attachée à sa culture
la soirée fut l'occasion de voir de très
jeunes enfants de différentes écoles de
danses traditionnelles d'heuliez en
invité d'honneur
une troupe composée de trente artistes
venus de shenzhen
[Musique]
et vous
non
ce très content de voir qu'il ya une
vente communauté chinoise qui est très
dynamique et qu'il vit harmonieusement
avec les réunionnais et ils font partie
des réunionnais bien sûr et en tant que
consul général de chine
je suis fier d'eux parce que ils ont
beaucoup travaillé dans le passé pour le
développement
économique et social de la réunion et
aujourd'hui je suis fier aussi d'être
invité
répondant à l'invitation de monsieur le
président des papas brutal pour cette
belle soirée qui est animé par une
troupe des artistes venus de shenzhen de
schille alors en tant que chinois je
suis très fier de leur présentation
c'est un beau spectacle
merci le président du département qui a
rappelé sa volonté de continuer le
travail avec le consulat de chine pour
permettre aux tories chinois d'être
accueillis dans les meilleures
conditions
ces dernières qui souhaitent privilégier
les et sciences économiques et renforcer
ce lien d'amitié très forts avec la
chine dans le cas d'une coopération
renforcée
[Musique]